[Music]
Thank You Kathy so in this session we're
going to talk about a few key concepts
will touch on API management for
cillessen multi-cloud so my name's Ruth
Paul Bogle I'll be the co-host of this
session for the the next 50 minutes and
we'll try and make it interactive and
and interesting so I'm part of the
Apogee product team I Drive a few
different areas for the Apogee team for
the core platform and then I'm also
today going to be joined by my partner
in crime
Kelsey Hightower who's gonna come in and
actually show stuff in action so just a
quick show of hands how many developers
in the audience excellent how about so
Ellis how many folks working with
serverless okay and just one last
question how many folks out here by
using multiple clouds today okay just
look around quite a few keep your hands
up for a second if you guys can look
around okay excellent
awesome so then you can't be the right
session so let's start with some
housekeeping rules here real quick so
this this time at next we are doing Q&A
a little bit differently we have couple
of mics here in the middle so you're
more than welcome to line up towards the
end of the session for questions but if
not you can also use the cloud next app
click on the Dory Q&A and ask any
questions out there as well
and towards the end of the session we
will just read up those questions and
just take our shot at answering it as
you go along awesome so let's spend a
few minutes talking a little bit about
serverless you know as I go spend time
with many developers they're adopting
solet's at their own pace but there are
key LEDs from serverless
which make it very attractive the first
one is the aspect of completely
abstracting away the underlying
infrastructure so developers love to
call and they want to really
deal with coal and say here's my code
just go make it happen just go run it
for me Oh business obviously there's
some other business benefits to be
ascertained from that as well such as
agility because you're working with cord
as a construct and you are not worrying
about infrastructure assuming a provider
can manage there for you you become more
fast at rolling out capabilities which
are more differentiated for your
business and gain competitive advantage
productivity is another key aspect of it
because you can do that faster you have
multiple teams who can collaborate and
build capabilities at a much faster pace
so solace is obviously catching up as
you saw today with a show of hands lot
of folks are looking at server less as
the next style of architecture in
building newer modern capabilities and
micro sources kind of goes hand in hand
with serverless in a big way usually
when folks are refactoring the
applications from monoliths into smaller
micro services
many of them are choosing serverless at
the key architecture style to build
those applications and clearly we have
seen a big evolution in server less then
so let's hit the stage a few years back
it was all about functions or also known
as functions as a service clearly
there's been an evolution from functions
to building full-blown apps and now to
serverless containers of course Google
Cloud has capabilities no matter which
server this flavor you pick but this
brings a very important element of
choice which is no matter what style you
pick you have the abilities in Google
cloud today to be able to leverage the
specific flavor and create a application
to power some awesome experiences just
like the internet happened
we believe that developers have a choice
they are going to use various frameworks
for very obvious productivity gains and
so
to control which framework they use
doesn't really work out because they
have a choice you want to empower
developers and make sure they have all
the access and controls to be able to
use the framework of choice but of
course as an organization you also want
to be able to put some method put some
control around it so you can manage it
very well but the reality is developers
are using many underlying frameworks
some of these which are mentioned out
here to build new capabilities but more
so are increasingly doing that on
different clouds just like yourselves
many customers are choosing different
clouds for various reasons it could be
it could be diversifying risk it could
be some clouds have some capabilities
better than the others right what I want
to do now is kind of poke a little bit
deeper into what we believe are some
other key differences between is service
so at the end of the day when you're
building a service application you are
delivering a service services of some
value to something right so let's say
it's a piece of code a snippet or the
entire runtime as we just saw in a
container the other spectrum of the
silver is flavor let's say you write
something in there let's pick an example
of an ordering system okay so you have a
small service that can take orders well
that so is that micro service is an
architecture style that's your back-end
if you would that's what you are writing
in terms of business logic as your code
as a developer now the moment that
service gets pushed out to a consumer so
someone who starts to access their
service that becomes an API so an API is
a contract this is the front-end of how
is service is usually accessed in many
instances these two concepts are assumed
to be implicitly together so as an
example when you roll out some piece of
serverless capability of course it has
an HTTP
endpoint but the clean line of
separation and we'll explain why why it
is the way it is as you start to examine
how folks are refactoring into newer
modern applications well it turns out
there were legacy applications or
monolith the applications which existed
before
turns out they were consumers who are
still using those applications so those
consumers are still using an API which
is the contract into an application the
difference is now you've kind of
migrated over to new server less style
of building applications so a back-end
has really changed it's very important
to understand this difference semantic
difference between a service and an API
and we'll touch on that a little bit
more so what does that matter at the end
of the day enterprises are building sort
of applications to eventually power
digital experiences right you heard
Thomas talk this morning about digital
transformation what does digital
transformation really mean it means that
in this day and age enterprises are
building digital products with nothing
but api's so aps have become the new
mechanism to express capabilities for
businesses and these api's which power
these connected retail experiences
whether that is powering an app that is
used by your employees or a third party
partner or essentially building an
ecosystem of different experiences you
know these API that really start to take
the value that you're building and sell
less and make it accessible to consumers
so let's take a step up and see well
great I have built some capabilities how
do I really manage this turns out the
moment you build some stuff which can
easily be accessed the very first thing
in you start thinking about is security
right is this soulless capability that
I've built
is it being active as someone who really
has the right to access or are
authorized to access that capability
right
I control it from making sure that it's
not abused
right of course so Alice is going to
give you endless scalability behind the
scenes for you right but you still want
to be able to ensure what is this a
business quota to it what if you have
signed up for that service and you are
really only allowed to use that at
thousand times a minute right because
maybe I'm offering a different tier of
service and one partner gets more fair
share than the other based on a
subscription plan the the other aspect
then we get into is great
how do developers and consumers or
soleus how do they really find out about
your service applications right is there
a mechanism for them to discover them
somewhere and lastly for the for the
enterprise it's also about great
we took this big effort of refactoring
our monolith and legacy applications
into modern serverless style apps how do
we know people are using them is there
an option what is my ROI these are some
very hard questions which technical
teams have to answer to their businesses
because someone is making investment in
that turns out there is a way to answer
these questions so an API management
platform brings a lot of these
capabilities out of the box so you as
enterprises can continue focusing on
building business logic writing code in
solar style development paradigms yet
have the peace of mind around how you
can use an API management platform like
Apogee edge to be able to control access
to your servers apps provide the right
level of security also provide the
ability for your service applications to
be discovered easily so that application
developers work consuming a service apps
can very quickly connect with them work
with them and then more importantly as
an entered
use some key dashboards which give you a
sense of adoption metrics operational
metrics well all those things are very
important okay so now let's take a
slightly deeper dive into what is the
API management for solace actually mean
so today in this session we're going to
very quickly demonstrate some real-world
capabilities using Google cloud
technologies including Apogee edge but
let's spend a couple of minutes on this
slide so turns out when developers take
on decomposing a big monolith
application the goal is to be able to
separate them out into discreet and
independent usable serverless
ass or chunks which means there's always
a need to take a bunch of these servers
applications and compose them into
something more meaningful so I spoke
very briefly about the connected
experiences that you're trying to
deliver ultimately whatever you're
building this server less is powering
some experience to a consumer so turns
out there are multiple ways and multiple
design patterns that you need to be able
to adopt to access these capabilities
which are now scattered across and
multiple functions or apps or even
containers so an api gateway which is
part of the APM element platform starts
to take a very central role in giving
you the tools and widgets to be able to
not only protect your service
applications but more importantly take
data from several of them compose them
into a higher-level experience API and
deliver that and in doing that you can
use a lot of capabilities from the APM
and platform such as ensuring the light
level right level of security right
level of access and the ability for you
to make some transformations or them
okay so with that I would like to invite
my partner in crime
see give a big hand I don't have any
slides hope that's cool so this morning
you heard about cloud run and you want
to use cloud run yet like one person do
you work at Google okay we had to check
so what I'm gonna do is so I'm gonna
talk about this kind of from the
practitioner level what's happening now
I guess if you strip away all the
buzzwords serverless multi-cloud all the
noise you just have more tools to build
whatever you need to build and ship it
so we'll start with cloud run is kind of
this new service runtime we have from
Google cloud my foray into the service
world I like the idea of these functions
and these code snippets but there are
some times where I just really need to
write the app in a way that I'm familiar
with some of the frameworks helps
sometimes it doesn't so in the case of
cloud run I can basically build an app
in a language I want build a docker
container push it to a registry and then
deploy it if you've never seen cloud run
in action I'll show you a little bit now
so I have a couple of things that we're
going to deploy we're gonna step through
this one by one
so cloud run is really straightforward
you know what you have is a very simple
application let's do this so this is
just a go app is really simple and the
goal with this whole service paradigm is
you're supposed to focus on the business
logic right so you're not gonna have a
lot of things like retries you're not
gonna do any of your typical things that
you would do with nginx I'm gonna put
that here just kind of kind of focus on
the business logic today my business
logic is just reporting the runtime that
I'm using right I want you to focus on
the overall architecture not necessarily
what this app is doing so when I
deployed this container it's just going
to respond cloud run the reason why I
like this particular paradigm is I'd
like to be able to develop locally on my
laptop using common tools so if I say go
build what I'm expecting is that I can
actually test this particular runtime on
my local machine and if I wanted to I
should be able to hit this with curl
using the familiar process that I've
been using for years most of this stuff
is data comes in data goes out it
shouldn't be that complicated
and you can see here that I hit it with
curl and it says cloud run this could be
any runtime any language we don't care
it's just going to make some system
calls you're going to get an HTTP
request and you're going to respond so
the way we deploy this is with docker
file so if you've used docker before a
very similar pattern I don't care what
you do in here you're going to end up
with some container image with some
entry point I'm using a two-step build
just to make this container super small
there's a lot of people in the service
community that hear containers and then
instantly just like catch fire I'm like
it's a packaging format right you can
ship source code you can ship a binary
and this is just another mechanism for
shipping a binary so if you look here
and my two-part build the only thing I'm
shipping is this small binary here and
I'm thrown away everything else ok so
this just gives me that flexibility to
deploy what I want in my own container
image then you ask yourself how do I
actually deploy this thing so you can
build this thing using cloud built so I
don't actually have docker installed on
my laptop anymore these days because I
use a tool we call Google or cloud built
and what I can do is I can submit my
source code and that docker file and it
would just build it here from my laptop
or I can use the CI CD flow and it will
just do it for me but the idea is we
want to make this as simple as possible
some of our IDE plugins this will be
automated for you so you hit save it
will do a build and then how do you
deploy it to cloud run itself we also
want that to be straightforward so if
you look at my deploy command that's it
the nice thing about this particular
pattern is if you already have a
container running on docker or in
kubernetes and you want to get rid of
the cluster you want to get rid of the
infrastructure you just run this one
command tell us what the image is and
we'll deploy it and run it for you and
that's serve list style we scale to zero
and we scale up on the request when it
comes so we run this command what you
end up getting is a URL so we'll click
over here so this is what the cloud run
URL looks like we also mentioned in the
keynote earlier that in cloud run you
can also bring your own kubernetes
cluster so if you're armed Prem maybe
you're already using gke you have a
collection of workloads
you just want to use that servlet style
that's serve this pattern you could run
these side-by-side so you can actually
say g-cloud deployed to this gke cluster
and it will show up in the same console
so you can kind of mix and match if you
really need access to like a GPU or some
specialized hardware that we don't do on
this stateless service platform here so
here's I think it's called run time and
it comes with the URL and tailor
certificate you can also map a custom
domain to it but he's gonna keep it
really simple one thing that we've done
is you don't necessarily need to use an
api gateway day one you can just hit
this particular endpoint and in my case
this is a private function so if you
authenticate to it then you'll be
charged if you do not authenticate to
this endpoint you won't be charged and
your function will never be invoked okay
so that's an important thing here so
we'll copy and paste this and you're
gonna run curl on my local machine and
we get this 403 and the reason why is
that I don't want people hitting this
container directly I actually want to go
through some proxy or some gateway and
this is where this Appaji piece comes in
as a developer what I want to focus on
is just that business logic and then
deploy my endpoints wherever that may be
so the first I'm gonna do is say hey
instead of me configuring authentication
here in my app we're just going to
delegate that to Apogee now last year
I'm pretty new to Apogee myself so last
year I've built a bunch of hacks to
create ooofff tokens to store an Apogee
key value store and then tell Apogee to
pull it out put it in the header call my
code I was like this is terrible I call
the effigy team is like there's no way
we work at the same company and I have
to do these kind of workarounds so they
built some extensions for me I was like
let me see them do they work that you
always ask your product team does it
work they always say yeah for some
reason so to think about this is there's
a new set of things called extensions
and what you do is you find one of the
extension so in this case I want
basically our Google off extension and
what the Google off the extension does
is the Google auth extension will allow
me to use a roth token or emit one for
me automatically let me go through this
let's see this off so here I just called
it cloud run but it's using the Google
authentication extension and what this
does is I can configure this particular
extension with a service account and
tell it what it's going to be used for
so if you click here you'll be given the
ability to configure this and deploy it
to one of your Apogee environments so I
basically have a set of credentials that
we don't show you on the screen I'm glad
because that would be bad
and then basically at this point this
particular extension using that service
account can then be referenced when I
create a proxy so if you're new to
Apogee like I am when I walk you through
a little bit of what this means so the
first step is we use this extension it
will start to create ooofff tokens for
me automatically behind the scenes and I
also have to give access in iam that it
can actually invoke certain functions or
cloud run instances so it's not going to
be able to call anything out-of-the-box
you still have I am control over what it
can and can't do now in the apogee space
we have to create these proxies so the
first one we're going to create is this
cloud run proxy and this is enterprise
stuff so we're using XML for
configuration I guess that I'm gonna mix
it Enterprise ready so you see all this
XML
don't die I almost did I had to come
back to life so the first thing here is
this extension so the nice thing though
is there is a UI composer you don't
really have to write all the XML by hand
so you should click on this composer you
can start to configure some of these
things so these things were set up ahead
of time let me close this out and what
you'll see here is the configuration for
this extension I'm saying I would like
to use the Google cloud run extension
using the Google authentication back in
and then you give it a couple of things
so I know from the documentation in
order to call a cloud run service I have
to give it this particular audience so I
know behind the scenes the extension is
going to use the Google API mint the
OAuth token using that particular
audience and then it's going to have the
ability to make that credential
available in this output string right so
if you can see here we have this output
string and this allows me to then
compose a call that will extract that
out and set it into the header and I'm
going to show you that configuration
really quickly and
to invoke this so what I'm saying that
when this particular extension is I want
to sit in header before you actually
call my app so you can actually see this
visual request preset of steps I can go
to the authorization header reference
that Google Cloud Run credential and
it's going to inject it in the header
for me automatically okay so the nice
thing is so this is the thing that makes
Apogee dope in my opinion just this
whole little trace thing I wasn't sort
of lacking did that my nginx why why are
you showing me this right now and then
he did this he click on the start trace
thing and you can actually see this
complex configuration like come to life
so if I hit this you can see that it's
going to actually move through each of
those steps and it's going to invoke my
particular function so you see here I'm
going to walk through what the output is
it goes out to the extension I'm gonna
show you some credentials don't be
hacking my service while I'm on stage ok
wait till later if you're on YouTube
this won't work at this point it's
expired my time you watch this alright
so down here I'll see if I can make this
a little bit bigger so down here we're
gonna have a bit of response stuff
happening here so this is actually going
to notice from all the read here it's
going to create that OAuth token and
it's going to store it in a way that I
can reference it here when I set the
header let's move this back so can I
collapse this there we go
all right all right so there we go so we
have this access token so that access
token is going to be extracted output
into a header and it's going to be used
to call the service underneath and then
you can see here that it's going to
respond cloud run just like my local
laptop so if I grab this now hitting the
apogee endpoint we can see that we hit
our particular back-end ok so then what
makes Apogee relevant to having multiple
applications so let's try something with
cloud functions so this is using cloud
run but we also want to do toy something
to cloud functions so if you never use
cloud functions this is a different take
on this whole service thing this is more
of a function as a service
and cloud functions you write code that
looks like this so you get rid of all
the server initialization and you just
write your handler so this is also going
we just write a normal go HTTP handler
you'll get your request automatically
and just like cloud run we also give you
an HTTP in point you can hit without
setting up an api gateway but in this
case I also want to make this also a
private function now this is deployed
using a different thing you don't build
a container first here you just use a
deploy command and looks like this so
I'm going to just be in my source
directory I'm going to configure this
particular thing to run as a specific
service account and if you look down
here I'm going to grant the Appaji
service account the ability to invoke
this function all right so that's
critical so the nice thing to about
after she extensions we also have an
extension just for cloud functions so
all you have to do is give it the
particular set of credentials and you
tell the function that you want to have
it and vote and you can skip a lot of
the boilerplate that I did a little bit
earlier but here's where I think Apogee
gets super powerful right the other
thing you might want to do with API is
is each of them will have some response
clients will hit your endpoint you'll
respond however you want but there are
cases where I see people that are
refactoring maybe it's a monolith and
you want to add a V to endpoint in that
case sometimes I'll build a small
function that adds a little bit and we
can enhance the particular response what
you can do an Apogee is I can actually
compose the response before it goes back
to the client so think about it this way
I can deploy a cloud function it's gonna
have its own response I can take both of
those responses and munge them into
their own output before I send it back
to the client so we walk you through
that configuration really quickly so we
have another API proxy and this one's
going to be called mash up so the
endpoint here is going to be this cloud
function mash up then we're gonna do
here is just going to look at the deploy
step and I have a bunch of these steps
that have been put in here so very
similar to the beginning we're going to
use the extension to grab the
authentication to call my first service
on cloud run and it's going to respond
with this run time and then we're going
to hit the lambda run time or not lambda
run time the cloud function run time and
that extension is going to call it the
cloud function
and here I'm just going to tell it what
region the name of the functions also
call run time and then I want to take
the response I'm going to show you the
configuration here so in this
configuration you can see that I'm going
to be able to reference the response
from the two invocations previous so
when I call cloud run we're gonna take
that output when I call cloud functions
I'm gonna take that output and here
instead of returning a raw string to the
client I'm going to return this JSON
payload that I'm composing here without
writing any additional code or hitting
any other back-end so what should happen
here is if I were to hit this endpoint
so we'll go over here to the overview if
I were to hit this endpoint this mashup
endpoint what we should see is both of
those functions being called one by one
and we should compose the response with
both of their runtimes so you can see
that there now so even with the Col
starts you can see the coal stocks are
pretty fast on both cloud run and cloud
functions and now Apogee is composing
the response from both of those
independent service calls into something
that I want to do for the end user so it
gives me the ability to compose and do
whatever I want without additional code
now there's one more thing that we want
to show you like where's the multi cloud
piece I typically don't say things like
multi cloud there's like multiple
environments where you want to do some
computation the hard parts about multi
cloud or multiple environments or
multiple cloud providers is composing
the network layer and the storage layer
so we see people do is they'll just use
best-of-breed so if you have if you're
using Amazon maybe you have a lot of
data and dynamodb you're probably just
going to use lambda if you have some
stuff inside of Google Cloud or cloud
storage your projects going to use cloud
run or cloud functions we're not forcing
you to choose so we've also built an
extension for lambda very similar to the
other stitches that I had before when
you write your lambda code if you've not
written any lambda good for you you're
probably only using Google services
that's what we want you to do but in the
lambda world
here's another go app very similar you
write a function main
you give it a hand to learn it's going
to respond now the response is a little
bit different in the lambda world and
you'll see when I merge them all
together but we want you to do is also
compose this multiple cloud thing for us
so averages are central control plan
it's our central entry point for all of
our clients but it has the ability to go
out to all the other end points and
aggregate all the responses so this is
what we mean by API management we don't
have to leak all of these details to our
end users if you're in the organization
and some people want to use one cloud
provider and other team must use a
different cloud provider you don't have
to argue too much you can normalize that
stuff on the edge so we go over here to
lamda going to show you that I actually
have it deployed to Amazon's lamda it's
just a standard it's also called run
time and then what we do is we're going
to show you the last piece here in
Apogee where we'll go to a different
proxy now I could have done this all in
one single proxy but I broke it up so
you can actually see the steps this
particular path is called multi cloud so
if I click on multi cloud you'll see the
various calls that I'm doing here so I'm
going to show you that configuration
here and you'll see hey don't be giving
me any errors in front of folks so the
first one here I'm calling out to that
cloud function like we had before then
here we're gonna be calling out to the
lamda using the lamda extension and the
nice thing about this lamda extension
just like I setup before with cloud run
I just give it a set of credentials so
you go to Amazon you create a set of
credentials that give it limited access
to invoke the lambda function you don't
need anything else and then I can refer
to that extension here and tell it very
simply the name of the function is run
time this is gonna be a synchronous
request response and then I'm going to
take that response that comes back from
lamda and hold it in this variable and
again just like I did with the cloud
functions I can take that variable and
then use it as part of that pipeline to
munge the response so the only thing I'm
doing here is taking that response let's
grow up I'm taking that response and I'm
adding the lamda response to it so we
should see an additional response in our
particular array all right so let's go
ahead and hit this endpoint to verify
that everything works so we'll click on
this overview here and then we'll grab
this endpoint to see if all three can be
invoked and we should get that much
response we'll click here
and we'll go back to our browser so you
see that there's two there now we'll hit
the multi cloud endpoint you can see now
we've added the response that comes back
from Amazon lambda as well using Apogee
to sit on top of all of those and it
gives you choice between any cloud
provider any servlet stack that you
would like to use with that like to end
the particular demo thank you thanks
goofy that was awesome you guys think
okay so what you saw Kelsi take us
through was something very powerful he
mentioned a few key capabilities that we
built around what we call it a P
extensions which give you the ability to
able it gives you the ability to access
many cloud services of course from
Google cloud platform and also from
other cloud providers as well so the
apogee API management platform is a full
lifecycle API platform which is a key
component when you start building your
service applications to ensure that
their access securely they have the
right level of controls in place and you
have right level of operational
visibility into it so if you start
looking at the different layers of the
platform it starts with the API runtime
what Kelsey was demonstrating today was
the core enterprise gateway and a set of
out-of-the-box policies which make it
very easy to take data from different
kinds of service apps do some
composition as he just saw the next
level up is known as a mediation engine
and that provides some of the core
capabilities around taking and
orchestrating data from different
sources in this case in particular
Kelsey demonstrated three different
types of extensions so two of the
extensions were actually just announced
today at this session the Google Cloud
the Google authentication extension and
the cloud functional extensions which
became available generally today so
those extensions were a perfect example
of how you can take capabilities from
different service apps compose them well
he took it a step further he all
showcased the lambda extension which is
available within Apogee as well
which you can use to go access your
service capability that you're building
on AWS as you go higher up in the stack
some areas we didn't cover today and
I'll show some screenshots real quick is
the API monitoring and analytics
capabilities they become very important
in the realm of once we have an API
program which is thriving and many of
you consumers are using api's you want
to be able to ensure we have the right
level of visibility not only from an
operational perspective of course taking
care of things like our my APS
performing well are they you know do
they have a lot of errors certainly
those kind of things to business metrics
around adoption right I spoke about
create your building service
applications who's using them right do
we have the right level of metrics on
adoption and if not some corrective
actions could be taken and the developer
ecosystem really touches on the next
level of how do I really get the
developers access to these kind of
applications which are nothing but API
endpoints at some point in time so I'll
just walk you through couple of slides
here real quick so this is an example of
the developer portal which is a key part
of the API management platform using the
constructs available here some of the
API endpoints that Kelsey was
demonstrating they we can very quickly
and automatically generate API
documentation which can be rendered on a
developer portal that any of the
application developers who are the
consumers of this soilless capability
that you're building can very quickly
access they can try them out and more
importantly they can register start
using those capabilities so developer
portal becomes a key entry point for the
consumers of your service applications
and the last I'll going to touch a
little bit on the consumption aspect of
it and monitoring and analytics so these
dashboards give you a very high level
entry point into the different kinds of
metrics the API platform captures out of
the box so just as you saw Kelsey
walking us through three different API
proxies the
and API traffic starts to pipe through
those API proxies we collect over 200
different data points and have
aggregations of datasets which can be
accessed over api's or also accessed
through the UI which Kelsey showed some
parts of it today
right so one example is the dashboard on
the top left we showed you the overall
engagement the overall traffic pattern
right
what kind of API calls are being made
how many of them are in error so on and
so forth and then you start to see some
other aspects of performance latency
analysis and then the ability to do
custom reporting right so none of the 20
or so or the walks - personal enough you
can actually go build your own custom
reports and this is a very important
feature because many times api's once
they become front and center of how you
serve data their different stakeholders
within the API program such as line of
businesses if you're building an order
API they want to be able to know well
how many orders are passing through of a
specific amount for a specific region
right you don't have to go out of the
platform you can use the custom report
to be able to just quickly whip up that
report and give it to the specific line
of business stakeholder who wants it
what does having to rely on getting data
out using yet another platform to build
that out okay so with that let's kind of
have Kelsey back over here let's kind of
summarize some of the key takeaways and
then we'll take any questions after this
so if you wanna come on over Chanelle
see so just three high-level key
takeaways I think we went through a lot
of things today but very quickly we
spoke about some of the service
capabilities that many of our customers
are dropping so clearly it's it's very
popular
you don't talk a little bit about multi
cloud and your experience yeah so I
think for me is the the service piece is
probably not going to be one provider
platform specific I'd look at them as
ways to program in the cloud sometimes
you're responding to events something
got uploaded to a bucket sometimes you
just have business Largent that you've
had for years and you just want to
deploy a via container and ID couple the
problem so as much as I like these fully
integrated platforms I do like the
ability to compose
I have a UNIX background I would like to
use an API gateway for a certain thing I
want to use different runtimes for
different things and what we talked
about today is the ability to compose
what you saw in my demo all so that I
didn't have to use Amazon's API gateway
I didn't have to use a load balancer in
GCP and I was able to pick and choose
how I want to orchestrate my particular
stack perfect and then last but not the
least as you hopefully would have
realized today API management is a very
vital function when you're building
soulless applications the moment you
expand the reach of those service
applications to your consumers you want
to ensure they are secured only the
right level of authorization is allowed
in terms of access you want to have the
right visibility so API management
becomes a very critical function as you
start to roll out more and more service
applications
[Music]